attention générale s est tabou c'est
parti olea merde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
mais
attention sur martin jol et à nos l'état
on terminera par vous guettez bataille
contre toi noël alors attention
giorgio et on va démarrer par l'onu
l'accord jean michel vous êtes prêt e
toujours attention c'est parti vous
passer massa chacun votre tour ici vous
faites une petite danse et je mettrai
des points pour chaque équipe je dirai
quelle équipe a gagné
[Musique]
m
si tu penses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soit
bon jeu mais rien sur as dans cette
équipe
ce carreau contre mercedes attention
carreau c'est parti on y va on y va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention ahmad jamal
pas mal attention mersen lâche ça va
[Musique]
ouais
la l'agonie qui vert pâle et qui ne
touche pas à mon poste
[Applaudissements]
mais rouler alors là oui
on a donn solas sk mode chasse aux idées
relais c'est tabou c'est parti la merde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment au psg c'est bon c'est
bon
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai pas
violetta de l'état qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé ça la défense laisse godasses
naissance et en totalité ses propres
antennes dans la paix en europe
pascal a dit avoir expliqué ce cas
regarde ça ne va pas pourquoi je ne sais
pas bon ce moment je crois je crois je
ne parle pas espagnol mais je vois qu'à
se fout de votre gueule
[Applaudissements]
c'était l'automne m
[Musique]
non
pour toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais bon
[Applaudissements]
bravo je mène pas ici par équipes de
tennis
violetta contre enora accord et simon et
égalité mokhtar présentera cette équipe
et j'en fais entrer cette équipe aller
où
elora c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
là
au menu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'espagnol n'a pas un jeu j'ai présenté
par balles et or tout compte
on peut tout faire et tout tout tout
théorie je suis si une promesse
promesses à bas les balles et tout et
tout et tout
elle me regarde attendait elle me
regarde bizarrement soleil auquel
s'était pas laissé moi je dis juste
préparez vous
vous
[Musique]
ouais
belga
tb
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
pas de quoi
pas du tout
le shérif je vais vous dire je vais vous
dire tuer pour mettre le point pour elle
aura par 12 pieds pour mettre le foie
pour une ora
de mettre le platine
en attendant on se calme on se calme
cela pourrait nous abandonnons s'il vous
plaît mais moi je vais vous dire je veux
vous dire au son os ou une nation après
ce que vous avez fait mais bien entendu
vous avez tout de suite vu le type
d'animateurs que j'ai terre avec fouad
twal a soudoyé aujourd'hui c'est cette
équipe le cas des biens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]